[Music]
and welcome everyone to another lecture
in tonight's lecture we will be going
over some games that I have played
recently it's called Grand Master's
choice so let's get go ahead and get
started so as some of you guys might
know I play a lot in the in the St Lou
chest St Louis Classics that take place
over here and uh the St Louis classic
are are pretty nice tourament to play
they have an average rating over 2600s
it's full of it's it's all Grand Masters
it's around Robin and um so you you're
pretty much guaranteed to get some good
practice because you'll play nine games
against strong opposition so in the
spring classic I I lost the first game
and I was really struggling in the
beginning but then I found my footing a
little bit I made three draws but round
number five was up against Sam savan and
in Sam savan he was one of the leaders
he was on Two and a Half out of four uh
I was on one and a half so I wanted to
try to you know move up in the standings
and uh try to put some pressure on him
with the white pieces also the day
before this Sam had to defend for like
150 moves against Dario s so I figured
that he would probably be tired and I
should therefore use my chance so I open
the game of with the move on D4 this is
how I usually play he played Knight F6 I
played C4 he played E6 so with the move
E6 he's intending to play the nimzo
Indian defense after Knight C3 and
Bishop to B4 now I also played against
Sam in the 2021 World Cup in uh in
Russia and there we had two games in
which I played Queen C2 I won one game
and U in the classical and but he drew
in a rapid uh and queen two's variation
I play quite a lot so I feel like he is
going to be very well prepared this time
around so I played the Catalan also a
very good opening so he played to D5
Bishop to G2 and here there's many
things black can do black can go forward
to move Bishop to B4 check there's
Bishop B7 there's also takes on C4 which
is the move he played and Knight F3 and
after Knight F3 here again black has a
lot of options black has this extra pawn
and they can choose how they decide to
want to hang on to it or just return the
extra Pawn there's a move like Bish
should be4 check there's C6 there's A6
there's Knight C6 Knight B D7 uh there's
also the move C5 and that is what Sam
played in this game move C5 is what Sam
almost always plays and uh I cancelled
he played Knight C6 and here white has
some options I can go for the move Queen
A4 there's takes there's moves like
Knight E5 but I went for the move D
takes C5 and I saw that he goes into
this end game with Queen takes D1 Rook
takes and Bishop takes
C5 and generally white can hope for a
very small Advantage here we're going to
get this Pawn back and I do that with
move KN bd2 taking the pawn Black Goes
C3 there's no good way to hang on to the
pawn so black just Returns the pawn uh
but damages my Pawn structure in the
process and castles and now some of you
guys might be thinking here like well
why is this end game like why would you
go for this end game with white right
the material is equal Black's got pretty
reasonable development and they've got
the better Pawn structure for now but
the thing white is usually hoping for is
this bishop on G2 which is better than
the bishop on C8 which is kind of
passive over here for now
so I played the move Knight B3 uh sorry
Knight B3 he played Bishop B7 and I
played C4 another move here is the move
Knight of D4 to open up the bishop right
away and put pressure on the Knight on
C6 so C4 now Sam develops his Bishop
with Bishop D7 and I go Bishop B2
putting some pressure on this s on F6
which is defending the bishop on D7 so
Sam played rook fd8 and again the funny
thing is Sam often played this plays his
variation so I had quite a bit of time
to prepare so I try to prepare deeply
for him and I think I came with some
good preparation I played the move
Knight F D4 all of this still has been
played again I want to put pressure on
this Knight over here he plays Rook A8 I
play Knight B5 he plays B6 all of this
again is still Theory and I play to move
Knight D6 attacking his Rook on C8 here
black has some options he decided to
trade off as Bishop for my knight on D6
black can also go for the move Rook C7
and here some games have ended in a in a
move for to after Knight B5 Rook C8 and
Knight D6 but if why wants to keep the
game going there's also moves like
Bishop to
A3 all right but Sam decided to take on
D6 I Rec capture and Bishop to E8 and in
this game we're both moving very very
quickly all right so after Bishop B8
he's offering the trade of Bishops I
take he recaptures and as we see now
white has the advantage of the bishop
air but again black is the slightly
better Pawn structure this Pawn on C4 is
a little bit weak so I defend it with
Rook to C1 and here he neutralizes my
advantage of the bishop Pair by going
Bishop to C6 there's no good way to keep
the Bishops on the board I mean I can go
F3 here but here you can't really talk
about the advantage of the bishop here
because my Bishop on G2 right now is
passive so I play the move C5 again this
will still all my preparation and with
the move C5 I want to get rid of my uh
isolated pawn and give him a slight
weakness on B6 so he takes AIC capture
he plays Knight D7 I take on B6 he takes
on C1 and uh I recapture question for
for everyone in the audience on on
Twitch and on and on YouTube If white
tries to be clever here with the move
Pawn takes A7 what does black play here
can anyone tell me to move here for
black what does black play into this
position what does black play this is
not a good move but can anyone tell me
why I mean doesn't look so silly we want
a queen over here to Rook is still under
attack but what does black play
here and in a situation like this where
there's two problems for black there a
pawn and The Rook you often want to look
for a move that solves both problems at
the same time indeed as the Casual
player has pointed out the move is Rook
to C8 mhm Rook C2 doesn't solve the
issue it solves the issue of The Rook
but not the issue of the Aon white
queens and White's winning but indeed
Rook C8 and black is winning all right
so samry took here Rec capture with the
bishop and he goes Pawn takes
B6 now here we were still following the
game that Sam played a year earlier with
the black piece against Ray Robson in
the American Cup and so we see that
white can perhaps hope for a very small
Advantage I play the move King F3 and
I'll explain why white might be a little
bit better my king is more active than
his this Pawn on B6 is very slight
weakness besides I feel like my knight
and Bishop have the potential potential
to be better than his two knights
because his two knights can do they can
do the same job but my knight and Bishop
can do different jobs so to speak all
right so so after move King F3 now Sam
played the move F5 he's stopping my king
from marching up the board okay so I
play King E3 I want to go King D4 and
now Sam plays E5 again stopping my king
from walking up and here I played the
move G4 Pawn sacrifice now Sam play the
move G6 but question to everyone in the
audience on Twitch and YouTube what is
White's idea in case black actually goes
ahead and takes the spawn over
here what is white idea why do I just
give up that pawn like that what do we
want to do
here what is the idea behind sacrificing
the
pawn
mhm exactly here we go King E4 and black
cannot stop us from going King D5 in
case they go here then we can go ahead
and uh and and take
here mhm and in case Black Goes let's
say king of seven we go King D5 and
again white has a good position the king
is going to come in the spawn over here
is weak there's ideas like Bishop to G5
to take this KN or King D6 for the
moment and in case of King E7 I can go
let's
say um
I one of these moves either Bishop G5 or
all Bishop G5 might be here I think it
might be Bishop A3 here followed by King
D6 if I recall correctly and black is
running serious risk here my king is
walking in this this Pawn is weak and he
has trouble creating a pass Pawn for now
on the king side so taking his risky Sam
played the move
G6 I took he recaptured and now I played
the move F4 again I want to open up
Square so my king can go in all right so
here let's say black goes E4 E4 is not a
not a good move here for
black um actually due to multiple
reasons we can go King D4 but also good
move is Knight D4 and there's no good
way to protect this all right so in my
preparation I looked at some moves here
Sam played the move knight6 there's all
also to move King F7 but again we see in
this end game that white always has a
slight Edge because this Pawn is weak
this Pawn is weak my king is more active
than his so the question really is like
can black hold or is white going to win
and that's really not a bad position you
you uh you want to be in especially if
you play against someone who's um who's
80 points higher rated than you I mean
in the worst game in in the worst case
the game ends in a Dr but his defense is
going to be unpleasant so Sam played the
move
knight6 all right I took he recaptured
and now for the moment both his Knights
are stopping my king from walking up the
board so question to anyone in the
audience you know here in in in person
or on Twitch and on YouTube how can
white try to pave the way for their King
to move up the
board what um what can I do here
can attack with the Knight mm so how kns
mhm and uh there's also Bishop would
threaten someone okay it's not going to
help you
move all right so let's go over some
moves that have been suggested some
people suggest the move Bishop B2 and I
think that was also the move you were
aiming at but Bishop B2 unfortunately is
not a good move can anyone tell me
why what does black do after Bishop
B2 Knight C exactly and take Bishop yeah
exactly Knight C4 and you win the bishop
mhm so so what is the move here then you
move your knight up you
got yeah for some reason it's it's
giving it away indeed the move is Knight
D4 and the position is already quite
critical for black I mean this Knight is
under attack this Pawn as well in case
black takes here or we recapture and
again we see that even though both pawns
only have three Pawns uh White's got a
White's probably just winning here cuz
Black's got a really tough time stopping
my king from walking up and picking up
this Pawn like let's see black goes here
I just go Bishop F4 to defend this Pawn
a king F7 King D5 you cannot stop this I
take here and then my a pawn is just
going to win the game all right so he
played the move F4 he played the move F4
all right so what do we do
now
King he exactly we have to go King E4
King E4 only move okay so he takes on D4
all right and here we can take two
knights so which Knight shall we
take all right so let's go over let's go
over to mve we can take this Knight over
here the thing is he can now take the
pawn on E2 um he can take the pawn on E2
we can also take this Knight over here
which looks pretty good the knight's on
attack and this Pawn as well
this looks pretty good for for white
right I mean let's say this n was here
to defend now again we go for let's say
King D5 King C6 we take the pawn and
this should be winning for white
but um Simon is there a way to turn
these arrows
off I don't
know I know so we we haven't se we saw
those arrows for the first time ever you
talking about how they're just pink yeah
well no they're telling us what the
moves are yeah they're they're telling
up top I I don't know how they work but
there some is the engine turned on it's
not the engine but it's um showing the
move that was played in the game let's
see well it's showing quote unquote best
move kind of yeah let me see if I
can I'm trying to quiz the audience here
but you know this this board is keeps
giving it away
okay become Grand exactly
maybe
preferences
so I would think maybe something with
display
or what
highlights is that no that's different
fish moves in Pre uh I'm not sure what
engine it's running it might be
stockfish I don't think it's necessarily
the engine I think it's just showing
that the move that was played in the
game oh no it's when it when it gives
you two different arrows like that the
big arrow is the recommended move the
smaller one you could do like it showed
moving that pawn down so um the if you
take then he takes the pawn backs the
takes the other Pawn m i I don't know
right now uh I'm going to go and try to
find someone who can uh who can help
yeah I mean if someone knows in the chat
also feel free to let us
know all right is there
um yeah okay this is
H all right
um okay but black has a move here is
there no no way I can turn these arrows
off black only has one move here to stay
in the
game can any don't tell me what is I
mean does Knights under attack this Pawn
as well black is a clever move yeah
moving that pawn down like it CHS with
the arrow because if you take with the
pawn then he check and takes your other
Pawn indeed so F3 is the only move I hav
moving what happens in case we take the
Knight he's he's going to
he's going to go F2 and his Pawn is
going to become a queen mhm
exactly exactly takes is not good
because of Bishop D2 mhm so we cannot
take the Knight so indeed we have to
take all right so here black takes an F3
and puts our king in check and here you
know the the margin between a win and a
draw is very thin because black is
getting rid of a lot of Pawns okay so
our King is in check King C4 and King D5
are both uh equally good okay so King D5
black takes here black has to take
because let's say they're bring their
King up now again we can go for move
like Bishop four defend the pawn we win
this pawn and our H Pawn stays on the
board and the H Pawn is really important
because the H Pawn this corner is of the
same color as this bishop but the a pawn
is not of uh the promoting square is not
of the same color of this bishop so if
black can take this pawn and somehow get
their King to this corner it's going to
be a draw but for the moment their King
is far away so we go King
C6 and here black brought in their King
as well with King to
F7 all right so how does white continue
here move is still pretty uh pretty
straightforward what does why do
here3 Bish B3 is possible but we lose we
lose time here black goes from for a
move like let's say um King
E6 or now I wouldn't say King E6 I would
say rather say King
E8 and I or let me think about this for
a
second yeah it feels like we're just or
or I guess King
E6 yeah Arrow yeah and like in case you
take black plays the move like Knight
of3 and the Knight the knight's moving
moving back like let's say you go A4 KN
E5 and it feels like black should be in
time to get a defensive setup like here
already black can go for something like
I mean Knight C4 stops the pawn and
black also has this H Pawn so black can
can create counterplay so don't make it
too difficult for your for yourself
right
here okay how can I turn this stupid
Arrow
off what should I do here don't again
don't make it too difficult
oh if it was me I'd do just what it says
i' take that pawn and start running
exactly you take the pawn black goes
king6 you can try but he ain't going to
get you and now what does why do
here uh move the pawn up to exactly we
go A4 Black Goes King
D7 yeah well let's have a look let's say
you go King
B7 here Black
Goes think about this r
black goes oh wait sorry that's
um here black goes here I
believe I think this was also I think
here and again like let's say you push
the pawn now now the Knight gets to
C6 and there's no you you don't get any
further and black still has this H Pawn
right which also makes sure that white
cannot it's going to be very difficult
for white to put black in
zuk because it's on white squares well
it's just more that let's say in a
position like this if you get your
Bishop to uh somehow to C7 right let let
me make some moves like let's say you
end up in in a position like
um like
this
um something like this could be
uh zwang but black again still his H
Pawn so it's going to be very difficult
to to put black in zwang all right
so all right so what should white do
here I mean damn can I really not turn
these arrows off I'm getting really
annoyed let me
see what does everyone think that white
should
do um King up is STO the other king from
coming across well King B7 we discussed
like the Knight comes back in
time
um it's very difficult to do so because
the Knight has multiple routes to get
back okay wait ah uh the
hamburger where is it yes there we go
thanks SP
okay the arrow is
gone okay so let's um let's think here
so we see that here's the
thing we can we can shoulder the king
but we see that it still takes a while
to push this Pawn up and in the meantime
the Knight comes back and it's quite
interesting so like I said earlier let's
let's go back real quick as I was saying
earlier I was in my preparation for a
long time I was in my preparation up
until the move F4 and at this point is
still had so you start off the game with
90 minutes on the clock and after every
move you get an additional 30 seconds on
the clock so at this moment I had an
hour and 39 minutes on the clock because
I gained time from the from the
increment I gained with every move so
here I still played this move move
quickly I I thought for a little bit
about this one these moves were still
pretty pretty
forced and I'm telling you guys this
position is not easy it again the margin
between a win and a draw is pretty thin
so I spend my time but after almost like
an hour I I figed something out because
A4 is good King
D7 so we see that going King here and
shouldering doesn't quite work right so
what else can we
do um if we
go we bring the towards the Knight well
that's not really the way to go because
if we bring the king back the king just
walks into the corner to the square yeah
like even if you lose the Knight it's a
dead draw because there's um there's
nothing you can do if the king reaches
here so that's really what this position
is all all about okay there's one pretty
there's one pretty straightforward move
that I think nobody both in in the chat
or in person has suggested what is also
move that white has to consider that's
pretty
straightforward
again I don't think it's a move that has
been suggested yet I didn't see it in
the
chat so we just played A4 black played
King
B7 so we see that with the move King B7
we want to shoulder the king and stop it
from coming here right but if the king
gets the C8 that's not the end of the
world it's all about stopping the king
from reaching
here P so let's push the pawn now black
is not in time to bring the KNE back
like let's say black goes here we push
let's say the N goes here we go A7 and
Black's just not in
time so indeed A5 is the move black
doesn't have a way to stop it like black
can also go for some some checks but it
all doesn't work like let's say Knight
Knight here I would just push check and
here there's no more checks on WE Queen
all right so after
A5 after A5 Black Goes King
C8 now here there's only one
move we know that if the king reaches
the corner it's a draw right so what do
we do
here with the King well King A7 we then
we put our King in front of the pawn and
now again the Knight gets the the time
to get back and this one should just be
a draw um
like Tak time
yeah so what is a more convenient way to
stop the king from reaching the
corner Bishop F four nice move very good
indeed we stopped the king from reaching
the corner all right so here it's
looking pretty good for white we stopped
the king from reaching the corner and
hey if we get a couple more moves we go
A6 A7 and with Queen so now is the
question can this Knight somehow get
back in time Black's got uh three moves
and I can go here here or here
um well let's say the Knight goes to F3
I believe we just push the Knight um the
Knight has to somehow try to give the
king a check right if the Knight goes
here we can just take if the Knight goes
let's say here we just push
and well we don't take the Knight
because then again the king reaches the
exactly but here we just push check and
King A6 and the game is over right so
black found the best move black played
the move Knight G4
all right so what do we do
now um say what what do we do now with
why this move isn't too too difficult
it's a pretty straightforward one I
think pushing the pawn again we just
push the pawn exactly right so we push
the pawn and now we're ready to go A7
and queen so again black has to find a
way to to somehow disturb me from doing
that so black only has two moves black
play the move Knight E3 also to move
Knight C6 they can try and as I was
calculating during the game I thought
okay Knight C6 I go King C6 and when I
saw this was pretty happy I thought like
okay here there's nothing black can do
black has to try to check me on this D5
square and for the reason that um after
A7 black can check here in case I go to
C6 then then I can let's say check me
here and I cannot walk out of the check
there's always going to be Knight B4 and
if I come towards the Knight then the
king reaches the
corner all right so um all right but in
case of Knight F6 here I go King King
C6 I thought the r game that this was
winning there's still to move Knight G8
but we'll get to that in a second but
black played the move Knight E3 and this
is where it gets
really um
this is where I here this is where I was
breaking my head so to speak because I
thought like okay if I push the pawn
black is just in time to stop me like if
I go here there's a check if go here
again there's a check and I can't get
out of this
right um so I thought okay let me try I
I played King C6 stopping the KN
check but here black can go for the move
Knight of5
with to move Knight A5 let's say I go A7
what does black do
then well
check
where right which one do you guys think
which one allows black to keep
checking well let's have a look let's
say A7 Knight D4 what do why do here
King B6 and Black's out of checks so
this wins this is a pretty this is
pretty good for white if you have the
king um diagonally away from the Knight
like this two squares away the Knight
cannot
check exactly so then again what does
black do after
A7 just have to use the process of
elimination
here so black has to go Knight E7 they
put me in check if I go here
che check again if I go
here no I B4 and it's a draw go to B5
keep repeating those moves exactly they
just keep repeating these moves and
there's nothing I I can get out of this
so here we just have to think like okay
we see now what black wants to do black
wants to check and and like jump jump
around
right so then we think like okay where
do we want to place our Bishop we see
that we want to cut off that King but we
also want to make sure that black
doesn't have all all these
checks so what could
be a good place for that
Bishop I would say Bishop D6 Bishop D6
excellent move Bishop D6 now here what
happens in case black takes the bishop
just push the pawn here we push the pawn
black cannot stop it and wide wins
excellent so question to uh everyone in
the audience and uh both in person and
online black only has one move here to
keep the game going what is it black has
to play Knight E7 check and again if I
take the Knight the king reaches the
corner and it's a
draw so D6 is a very good Square for
that Bishop specifically because in a
lot of these variations there's not that
Knight before before check that we saw
earlier right so black played Knight
E7 all
right and um what does yes King B6 let's
say King B6 okay we're threatening this
what does black do
here Knight B5 right exactly now Black
Goes Knight
B5 and um yeah they just keep checking
like if we go here he just go Knight
here there's Knight B4 and black draws
by force attacking um pawn and if you
take there's this
so here's like like I said earlier I
spent like an hour earlier on on a
position but I found a concept here that
I was very happy with what does white do
in this
position you have to move the
king so where should the king go
maybe King C5 to box the Knight out king
C5 very nice move the Knight can now not
join the
action and so here's the thing we're not
threatening to go A7 because there's
King B7 we don't threat to take the
Knight because there's King B King
B8 but maybe we can hope that this
position could be zuk song If the Knight
moves let's say here then we go King B6
and A7 and we win cuz like now now all
of the stuff with Knight E7 does not
work because we go here and the bishop
covers this square there's no longer
than Knight B4 check all right so
there's the idea of zuk wrong but then
the question is what and initially I saw
this but then I I saw wait but what
happens in case black goes here attacks
my Bishop if I move the bishop back
let's say here then again they go here
but what do why do in this
position King B6 right King B6 and in
case black
takes you push the pawn then in case a
check King A6 King A6 excellent and
black cannot stop the pawn and this is
really what this position resolves
around this position over here is zuk's
swong black cannot move the Knight they
cannot move the king but they still have
that that H1 and and like I said earlier
in case of Knight A5 there's King B6 so
here black played H5 all right so what
do we do here with white
there are multiple moves that are
winning but just what is the what is the
winning plan so to
speak and the nice thing is sure what
well King
C4 might be a move but you can bring the
maybe the Knight goes here so I like I
like this Construction
we see the black is in zuk zong now the
nice thing is black can push up this
Pawn but our Bishop controls the square
and eventually black is going to run out
of
moves and again there there are multiple
moves that are winning here but just
uh just what is the winning winning
plan King B5 has been suggested in the
chat but then Black Goes Knight
D5
D4 uh King D4 then there's here and
that's an immediate
draw again I like this I like this setup
keeping the king and the bishop here we
know that it's s the Knight cannot move
as then there's here so black can only
push this Pawn oh but um I especially
like the king here because it's taking
away D squares from the
Knight
if you play King B4 you have you have
Knight D5 and Knight C7 right I think
yeah I think that's an immediate drawing
because King before Knight D5 and then
Knight
C7 and the King reaches a yeah
mhm exact yeah so any other
ideas
see the moving the king doesn't quite
work
right well move the bishop so then we
can move the
bishop what do they call that a waiting
move we just call that a waiting move
yeah so I think really moving the bishop
anywhere is fine in the game I played
Bishop to H2 okay all right so this
Knight can I go here can I go here
because we take it I can it can go here
or here so in the game my opponent
played Knight to G6
and what does white play
here King to
B6 but in case of King B6 the Knight
goes here and back yeah so A7 there's
here and then Knight B4
check we need that Bishop like that's a
difficult
thing so what does why do here how do
we well this one is not don't worry
about it at all pawn pawn this one is
very
difficult took me a long time time to
figure out but what does why do
here but again I I'll give you guys him
black is running someone suggested
Bishop D6 in the chat but then black
goes here and we are back at the same
position so how do we go about and we
have to put black and zuk swong I'll
give you guys that so we don't
necessarily have to do something we just
have to make sure that black runs out of
moves if you play C6 you just go back to
E7 right you're got to get back to B4
squ exactly King E7 and um yeah Cas of
here there's
check
yeah King D6 will suggest about a casual
player but then King B8 and King B6
there's Knight here sorry Knight here
and the Knight starts
jumping and it's all about zuk swong we
move that Bishop earlier the Knight goes
here
I think you should have to wonder like
okay where where can that Knight
go the Knight can of go here canot go
here it's probably going to go back here
right because it needs to be on E7 to
give those important checks on D5 and
B4 but after Knight E7 let's say black
goes Knight
E7 what what do we
play we know how we want to put black in
zuk Swang
right like let's say we we passed here
and black goes 97 what was the move
there to Black to put black and zuk song
after 97
y we had a very similar position
earlier D6 exactly
when Black Goes Knight E7 we go Bishop
D6 and black is in zuk's swong again the
Knight cannot move the Knight can go
here but then we go King B6 right and in
case of takes there's A7 Knight C4 and
King A6 and we win the game so now we
see that hey if we can pass black might
end up in Black might end up in zuk they
can push this Pawn but at some point
they're going to run out of moves with
that P with that pawn as well
right so then how do we pass black the
move make mm B G3 exactly we go Bishop
G3 very good yeah Bishop G3 I mean F4
and E5 are not available so we go here
Black Goes Knight E7 and now now B6 and
now we go Bishop D6 excellent black s
zook song so black pushes up the H PA
black went
H4
um all right and and here what do we do
now
Bishop H2 Bishop H2 is a move but the
problem is now black goes
here and he just slowly advancing his
Pawn it's not necessarily that they're
slowly advancing the pawn but here we
don't have a good waiting move we don't
we don't have Bishop G3 we don't have
Bishop F4 we also don't have Bishop
B5 and we can go here but we want black
to be the move in this
position right so the question is how do
we go about losing the tempo where do we
go with our
Bishop
E5 E5 is a is a good move I think F4
might be fine as
well um but I went to
E5 all right so my opponent
went Here and Now
and indeed as someone suggested in the
chat in case oh sorry in case black goes
here then we go Bish page two and that's
kind of again the position we want right
97 Bishop D6 oh sorry 97 Bishop D6 all
right
so um so black playing that a five and
now so now do we just go
king6 well in case of King B6 again
there's Knight
E7 and black is checking
us so that's still too early we still
have to put black in zuk
swong so how do we do
that
you guys are getting very close but we
just have to keep making waiting
moves Bishop F4 exactly so we just go
Bishop F4 mhm we again give black the
move pitch two here is not the move why
not Knight G3 Knight G3 exactly the
bishop was blocked out and now black
reaches the corner and it's an easy draw
so we go
Bishop exactly and taking we we even
lose yeah so Bishop F4 black play Knight
E7 now what do we do Bishop D6 Bishop D6
exactly and black again is in zuk swong
so um again as we see in case of Knight
F5 we go here case of takes and there's
A7 this we know by now and again the
difference why why do we want this
bishop on D6 because in case of here we
push and we go here and we win all right
so in this position black played
H3 all right so here again there's
probably multiple moves so but what do
we do
here
I think to be honest pretty much every
move is fine
here yeah Bishop E5 should be fine I
play Bishop
H2 all right and so my opponent played
Knight
F5 and now um I played Bishop to F4
again passing black the move all right
so
here let's say black goes Knight E7 what
do we do
now we still go Bishop D6 right we still
go Bishop D6 and the nice thing for
white is that in case let's say black
goes here again there's this and we
Queen one move earlier Queen one move
earlier and stop black from from
queening so that's also a nice uh detail
in this position all right so black
realized like okay after Knight E7
Bishop D6 they're in zuk swong they can
push up the pawn but I'm going to take
and eventually they'll they'll end up in
in zuk swong again so black played
Knight
E3 black play Knight E3 all right so
what do we do now we were we're getting
closer and
closer what are we play in this position
how do we continue putting black and zuk
on
okay King C6 looks very tempting right
to go A7 and queen but what does black
do
here again like by now we know where
black wants to
check Knight C2 excellent we know that
this check on B4 is really important so
they can go to B4 and then go here and
here there's not much that white can do
I mean again in case you push there's
check check and black draws you canot
get out of this so King C6 is too
early so how do we prepare that move
and we know now what setup we
want
cannot okay but in case of King B5 again
like the Knight the Knight jumps here
goes to C7 and then it goes to C7 and
and it's it's a draw it's an instant
draw maybe Bish
E5 okay Bishop B5 is possible but then
uh let's say then I can jump back again
okay so we know we know what set of we
want
right okay I mean again know that this
check these checks on D5 and
B4 are important for Black's defense so
what is the setup we need for
white
need King D6 again then the king runs
over like the king is fine here or
here but where do we want the bishop to
make sure that black doesn't have all
those
checks on D6 exactly so here we go
Bishop D6
again and again in case of Knight F5 we
go King B6 we've seen this already a
couple of times so black did something
else black played the move Knight to
C2 all right and now what do we do
here this
is this is another hurdle that we have
to overcome what is why play in this
position
k a bishop F4 black can go Knight
knight3
back so you think King B6 then you can
just do
knight uh King B6 looks tempting because
what happens after KN
B4 you can't right you can't take the
Knight right you can't take the Knight
because black goes here but what do
white playing this
position
no here actually we just have A7 because
in case you check both these moves are
winning can just go to like to C6 and
the Knight cannot check us anymore so
this wins but King B6 so we see Knight
B4 loses but black has a
way to to draw here how can you improve
on that variation for
black B7
KN A3 again we see that the check from
C4 is not very effective because you
just go here and the pawn
Queens so we saw that variation earlier
right with Knight B4 didn't quite work
but try to find a way to make it work
like can somehow
change change the position in their
favor
what if you push the pawn first exactly
Black Goes H2 white has to take and
now and now Knight and now Knight B4
A7 exactly and the checks don't yeah
because the bishop is not here all right
so we see that King B6 does not
work so then what does why do here but
again like we see that often the direct
approach it doesn't work right so maybe
we have to look for zwang
again someone suggested King C6 but King
C6 allows Knight
B4 and oh here if you take actually
loose so Knight B4 AB but there's even
yeah so again I'll give you yeah again
it's it's it's about still it's about
zuk
Swang what about Bishop
H2 okay let's say we go Bishop H2 then
the Knight jumps
back yeah I think we just came from
here and this bishop here is well
placed
all right so someone in the chat
suggested King B6 but then there's H2
takes a KN B4 as we saw
earlier right so what is the move
here
again this is another nice finesse we'll
have to
find here if you move the king and
probably just over this but the king at
C6 he's going to check right he gets
this
check
yeah so maybe charge the
Knight you just want to make sure that
this Knight does not join the
action but if you play King C4 then you
just you just check and you're back in
time right yeah King C4 is kind of a
step in the wrong
direction have to make sure this this
Knight does not um show any action some
some people in their chats have found
the move
but so I'll help you out I'll I'll help
you guys out a little bit we see that
moving the bishop does not quite work
right we really need this bishop over
here because if we move it back again
the black can the Black Knight can jump
back to E3 and it will get back to one
of the the squares where it needs to go
so we need this bishop over here see
moving the king up doesn't quite work
because this Knight always somehow joins
the
action here white is
another so maybe it'sing D5
well in case of King D5 then again
check
so what about
um if King B5 do you have
knight4 let's have a look at that let's
look at King B5 Knight D4 this check
isn't very effective now we go King B6
again we have that diagonal domination
of the Knight that we talked about
earlier the Knight no longer has any
checks and then there's
A7 A8 so King B5 interesting move and we
pass black the move this check isn't
very effective this check over here I
think we go to
C6 and again A7 is is a big threat so
King B5 is actually the move black again
is in zuk swong all right so black
played Knight E3 all right so what do we
do now
at this point go to
that King
where B6 now well King b6o early yeah
it's too early black
uh checks
here and it Cas it here then again
here M this too early but you guys are
close
and our Bishop is ideally
placed see the king B6 doesn't
work but what do we
do
[Music]
exactly we go King C6 and now we threat
to go A7 and queen and what can black do
in case let's say black goes
here um or yeah like again black doesn't
even get the check here like let's see
here push Knight B4 we can even just
take so King C6 all right so now we're
ready to go A7 and A8 so black goes
H2 okay what do we do
now this one's we have to take the pawn
yeah otherwise black promotes okay so we
take and now Black Goes KN a
five okay so we're very close you will
see we put black in a in a in a lot of
zuk swong so we got rid of the H Pawn
but we have to keep putting black in zuk
swong pushing the pawn up is still too
early because of check here or like
check here and
here exactly so what do we
do
five should be five is possible but they
check well again what is the set of that
we want where where do we want that
Bishop on D6 exactly so here we go
Bishop
D6 so again in case black takes we push
the pawn and we win this check doesn't
help we go here and this Knight is going
to promote so black goes Knight E7 and
again in case we take the king reaches
the corner so what do we do here
we've seen this position already a
couple of times
but King C5 excellent and this is the
final zuk swong and the King cannot move
there's A7 the Knight cannot move can go
anywhere so black play Knight a five and
now no A7 is too early then King
B7 now King B6 King B6
again we see that in case black goes
here they run out of checks let's say
black goes here by the way what would
you do with
white king A6 right King A6 yeah King C6
might still win but there's Knight C7
and in case you take it a still mate
okay so in this position black took the
bishop and now I a A7 check king6 King
A6 and that's it black cannot stop us
from queening and so I won this game but
yeah great job you guys you guys worked
your way through the through all the zuk
songs um but yeah it was really great to
uh to win this game it felt like I
almost created a a study with all of
these all of these zuk swangs and yeah
some please define zwang a zwang zwang
is a German
word it's
um I don't know the the English word for
Zang but it's like move like you're
forced to move you're forced to make a
move that worsens your position and
that's what we see here um after King C5
in this position black would like to
pass black would like black would just
like to press the the clock and be like
okay it's your move but you can't you
have to make a move and same thing goes
for white white would like to just press
the clock and pass the move to to Black
so black has to make a move here that
worsens their position if it's white to
move here we don't have anything that
worked right we saw that King B6 there's
always Knight E5 but the problem is that
the the black has to make a move right
so do that Mak
sense all right
so yeah that's uh that's pretty much it
I I managed to to win this game and that
actually held me on the way to to win
the spring classic over here in uh in
but yeah this was definitely one of
perhaps one of the best games I've
played in my uh career but all of you
guys did uh did
great all right so thanks everyone to
both here in the audience and online on
Twitch and YouTube we're going to sign
off for today make sure to tune in
tomorrow I will be streaming and playing
viewers from 1 to 300 p.m. Central and I
will be doing another uh lecture at 7:30
p.m.
central
[Music]